bonjour et merci d'être avec nous en ce
24 décembre une grande partie de
l'après-midi intéressera les enfants en
effet à partir de 15 heures dorothée
vous fera découvrir le pays où les
habitants sont des chansons chansons
tristes chansons gaies chanson tim hill
chanson rock chanson d'amour
une comédie musicale donc à 15 heures
avec dorothée au pays des chansons à
15h55
un film un film truculence humour
bagarre avec miou-miou robert charlebois
terence hill qui se livrent à une
parodie de western ag ni une cloche deux
associés 17h50 magie majax les comédiens
et les chanteurs qui seront auprès de
gérard majax devront absolument savoir
faire des tours pour mériter leurs
cadeaux de noël
parmi eux darry cowl karen cheryl alain
bashung
les enfants ne seront pas exclues de la
veillée noël en effet ils seront 2000 à
20h30 à l'opéra de paris assister au
spectacle qu'animera patrick poivre
d'arvor un spectacle donné par
l'orchestré de l'opéra dans les ballets
de l'opéra les petits rats les danseurs
étoiles par des comédiens français tels
que jacques tjat enfin par des chanteurs
comme yves duteil et michel berger et
cette joie de noël à l'opéra de paris
s'achèvera sur le lac des cygnes et puis
tout le reste de la soirée nous le
placerons en compagnie d'artistes
également à 23h30
angelo branduardi qui interprétera une
dizaine de chansons à 00h10 georges
brassens à qui nous rendront hommage en
rediffusant une émission que pierre
tchernia lui avait consacré en octobre
1975 pour un air de guitare autour de
georges brassens il y avait maxime le
forestier pierre louki marcel dadi roger
pierre et jean marc thibault et enfin à
1h10 avec herbert von karajan filmé par
françois reichenbach
nous verrons comment travaille le chef
d'orchestre et nous assisterons un peu à
la genèse d'un concert évidemment nous
aurons l'occasion de revenir sur tous
ses rendez vous tout au long de la
journée
je voudrais vous signaler que dans
quelques instants
allons retrouver philippe bouvard c'est
là 499e fois aujourd'hui qui nous
donnent rendez vous bonne journée à tous